foreign
[Music]
in order to get ourselves in the
ballpark
of the discussion here
is we have to figure out what we're
doing
and what we're not doing
okay
so this is called Q Hall
the whole
kanji denotes like cultivation drilling
is probably the best translation
I'm Drilling
um
you can't look up Coq in a dictionary
it's not going to work
and its meaning is really really old and
by circumstances quite esoteric
so rather than go through that full
history we'll just say it does not mean
breath
is it unrelated to breath no I didn't
say that but it does not mean breath so
you're not going to breathe your way
here
in fact you could drill Coq
and use Coq in the larger sense
while
holding your breath
exhaling inhaling whistling singing it
doesn't matter what you're doing with
your breath
it does not mean breath
so you're drilling to call Q
to gain the skill of Coq and what is
that skill
it is
the young variant
of
internalizing
energy
as a young variant it has particular
characteristics
but none of those characteristics are
antithetical to the yin variate variant
of internalizing energy
so at a certain point
the invariant
is not
clearly distinct
from The Young variant
the yid variant is I
why have a drill and not call it I.T
hole
you could have you could have
but in my experience
there is a passivity to iking
if more happens
as a result of something not happening
so to cultivate ID
is kind of weird
but I can't cultivate coffee
but in the cultivation of Coq the
cultivation of the young variant of
internalizing energy
you're going to have to do I
cannot not happen
but there's another reason
for why you would have a cookie hole and
not an IP hole well first reason is you
you will have ipoid
right and then the second reason is Ike
no I.T hole because it happens past
e but the third reason is
that from a pedagogical point of view
what like what helps the beginner move
from no Coq no internal skills to having
those skills it is much easier to go
through Coq than to try to go through it
okay
so
that said
when it when it's not it's not sparring
it's not self-defense
it's not a risk grab defense
um
it's not a throw
the fact that he is thrown is irrelevant
to the drug
okay
um it's not a technique either oh it has
it become a technique yes it has
has it become a throw yes it has has it
become some sort of risk grab yes are
there people who go uh no one would grab
you and sit like that in front of you
he'd just punch you you can see they're
working from a sparring point of view
this is all degeneration all it
happens both inside Aikido and outside
from outside Aikido looking at quotes
in that sense what you're doing is very
akin to as an analogy is if you want to
let's say you have a martial concern
and uh he knows from experience it's
better to be stronger than weaker from a
martial concern
so he's going to work out
he's going to lift weights and he's
going to be very strong he's a very
strong dude
but that doesn't mean he can fight
so he develops that skill
and with that skill he goes on to
develop
his martial capacity
likewise call Q
is not in itself a marshall
skill
but once you understand poke you once
you understand I key you have to go on
if you from a martial point of view
you have to go on to figure out how to
use it
you're not going to use it like this I
sit down here and he grab some okay this
is a drill
so as a drill or as a skill development
that I would later use marshally by
developing myself martially with
technique
with strategy
with experience just like lifting
if he's doing bench press
I don't come by and go that far
does not hit back
that this is
this person does not understand
what a true martial concern is okay
the bar has an expected role in order
for him to develop himself
strengthwise for a bench press let's say
so too desert UK
in Pokemon
they have an expected rule
their expected role is to touch me at
the wrist
and finally displace me with their own
Coq
projection
while he's doing that
'll provide the energy that I
internalize
let pass through my body
go down onto the ground my contact point
with a greater mass
in this case the ground
bounce off of the ground back through my
body
and into
the center of his body
not back into his shoulders
okay
whether he falls or does not fall is
irrelevant what you should see is as if
you come over here
they'll be like a projecting Force into
the center from how he's sitting now
that's about where his uh hemo is on his
hakama okay and it'll look like if
somebody grabbed him from the belt and
kind of pulled that thing out okay so
let's watch his Center
and uh you can go gradually but slow
and you can see that part right there
where this kind of caves around it okay
we'll do it again
right there
is what you want to look for
so I'll show you some contrasting things
a contrasting uh diff so what I'm not
doing is I'm not trying to create a lean
in his body by manipulating his line of
gravity
okay I'm not trying to take this hand
this way lift up his elbow and then just
lean his line of gravity outside his
face of support So if you watch his
Center and it just kind of
fills out
can you see that
okay
you can do the same arm techniques you
know I have a Yin arm out here right cut
over the top and I have a yam arm over
here can still have this elbow up but
something different happens to a center
so in this one he kind of rolls out of
his basic support and on the other one
out
inject his Center out of his face
that projecting that's indicative of Coq
okay
that separating energy him from me is
indicative of Coq
and I he is a invariance so there's no
projection there's a drawing in and
there's no separation there is a
communion and adhesion okay so for
example just to show it and get in the
conversation this goes into his center
right there
in this Center or right here is that I
can use that IP adhesion see that so as
I'm drilling Coq
boom hot
[Music]
a loose connection again I can
accelerate his energy into me with not
by getting out of the way but with that
same IP adhesion so here I'm going to
use that adhesion here I could be on the
outside and use that energy
foreign
go back to the idea that he has a
prescribed role
his prescribed role
sets up
the drill
I'll be the UK
when I attempt
to gain a Coq projection of his Center
you see of his Center
and he does not let himself be projected
from the very beginning we have
established a center to Center
relationship
what would not be that
is here
loose
or
shoving my shoulders knees
that's only here
my
cohere engagement starts as you get
where
you have it
not by here in shoving
but generating the initial
relationship there it is right there now
he's pushing it into my Center I'm
pushing into his Center
what he's going to do now is let that
energy pass through him full and then
push it back into my Center
to get it to go
watch what can happen
if I start changing my role
so I I didn't do it
there's no initial training drill the
bar is not on the uprights
okay or I do start it and when I feel it
I now went limp again
it's loose again
so I have that relationship
and my goal is UK is to keep that
relationship so that he
can send that energy down
I go
I just look escape from that
relationship
if you watched the energy that he's
projecting up to move my go ahead do it
slow the energy that's coming back into
my body right there
I will absorb in my arms
okay now the bar on the bench press all
of a sudden got all rubbery it's not
working for my skill okay so to set the
drill up
you establish the center to Center
relationship that means my Center is in
my hands and my energy is going into his
Center down he will
feel that aim it back into me and there
is
so to speak the initial conflict that
the Jujitsu will reconcile okay it will
reconcile it internally though
on top
okay let us get there
so
one thing was already said
and that is that when I project that I
don't reject into your shoulders
I'm not projecting here
okay
so someone who might not have ever
experienced this
tries to figure it out with the tools
that they have okay and for example
if they are doing Coq whole and they're
practicing a throw
this kind of throw
or
by extension what is that that's just a
manipulation of your uh
your frame let's say or your posture
such that your line of Gravity Falls
outside your base of support and then
you will tilt over
yeah I know
are you all right
any any of those versions so you know I
can hear using and then I turn
it is an external manipulation of her
shape such that her line of Gravity
Falls outside her face of support and
she is her balance which she then
recovers with the goal okay
um
another external manipulation is the one
where I just push into your shoulders so
you have a job to do you did not do your
job there so I'll correct you first you
have to find my Center find my Center
okay got it and I would say already
you're you're already in your shoulders
when you do that one okay but go ahead
and do it and I'm not supposed to do it
back to you
so I'll use you a lot here okay so the
person is pushing at me and someone
trying to figure out what is going on is
gonna think that because she has her
arms straight
that I'm just pushing into her shoulders
okay but uh if we go if we go while
that one didn't go on her shoulders
clearly my hands were her hands are way
below her shoulders okay
um
another one
is
when I go to push so I'm not pushing
like this
and you're not supposed to push back
like that
if I pick up the energy
you will never
be able to do it
okay if you're doing shoulder to
shoulder push at external manipulation
okay so we go and I
keep that pressure off
she'll never every time she pushes into
my shoulders
why are you gonna do it do the technique
it'll never happen do you see
I'll show you
[Music]
the more he increases the pressure
more he's really trying to get my Center
going do you get it
the opposite happens
so if I'm doing it internally
the more he energy he gives me the work
with
the actual easier it is
when you do an external manipulation the
more energy you're given to work with
the less you can do with it it just
overpowers you okay so uh he's gonna get
tired because he's putting all that
energy and you'll see like let's say
like medium energy you can see look at
how much movement that was
that's still a lot of movement
but he pushes hard
last movement he's really driving
[Music]
if you do understand that so that's the
distinction okay
um
so we're gonna pick it up now it's some
of you are going to get shut down
because you're just here and you're just
trying to shut up
okay
so Trista was able to kind of shut two
of you down but I would I want I want
nagas to be shut down okay and only the
the Nuggets that can do it
they'll be moving less
and doing it Drive
foreign
okay
and again you can see the trajectory is
in the center not in the shoulders okay
let's
[Music]
foreign
Okay so
uh
I'm now I'm looking at this thing and
I'm trying to figure out I've never felt
that
uh it is I would say
in Aikido
it is more likely that you have not felt
these skills
you have you have in essence
a lot of
unsophisticated to sophisticated
external manipulation of someone's
equilibrium for the most part makes up
most Ikea
and then a whole lot of cultural fiction
that supports the delusion
[Music]
that somebody of high rank
has these skills they they don't they do
not my teachers did not they don't
simultaneously you have another art
that is connected historically to the
founder
that in my opinion is doing something
radically different
when they talk about internal skills so
daito U is doing something totally
different
for them they believe or they pause it
or they suggest
that what they're doing is different
by which they mean better
so
yes there might be some Chinese
influences or there might be some uh uh
coming to a different Solution on the
same problem
but there's an air that is better and I
would say it's not
I would ignore completely what that
lineage is saying as far as internal
skills and stick with this stuff okay
there is a longer history with many more
Arts that understand
yin and yang
internally not just externally
and understand it as just generally
described here a young separating energy
and a Yin communing energy
in that vein there are so many countless
Traditions that make
way more divisions way more categories
to describe what is going on some get
very poetic uh some get very esoteric
and Isis
to me it is irrelevant because none of
it
helps you actually get these skills
and we will have to discuss why
all of those things
no matter how scientistic they get today
such as it's in your fascia
is all poetic they are all upaya they
are Pointers
trying to get somebody who has no
experience of it to to experience it to
become sensitive enough to experience it
and distinguish it from what it's not so
so far as you guys were going we could
see that many of you thought koku is
just sending energy back up the
shoulders and kind of
taking advantage that he had
rigidity in his arms but it's not that
so let us continue to look more
into what it is not okay so
um
I described it and and here I am telling
you how I'm describing it is equally
poetic meaning as a new Pia it both
points to what you're trying to do but
as a new Paya is also an obstacle to
what you want to try to do okay
which means it's both true and not true
so the poetic that I use
is that his energy is going to go down
into my body and down onto the ground
that's the imagery that you're using
okay
um
let's see
so some might look at this and go no
this is just a skeletal alignment and a
sound body mechanics okay so uh yet it
failed us when the guy pushed really
hard
so
what I described poetically is that
energy is going into me and going down
there's nothing in that that says I need
to have good skeletal Alignment good
posture or anything at all do you
understand okay so for example if he's
pushing here you you can look at well
that you have skeletal alignment and uh
you're just have sound body mechanics
okay but there's some problems here my
go ahead and keep pushing my arm is not
uh rigid so this this would make sense
to a secular materialist but this starts
to not push really hard this starts to
not make sense
okay and same as I start going here
this doesn't make sense you can do
different things
this doesn't make sense push this does
not make sense I have terrible mechanics
okay push terrible mechanics
moving back into position does not make
sense
life-wise
he's he's out here and he's pushing
if I can take the energy that's coming
forward and put it and taking it off the
straight directory trajectory that the
secular materialist sees
and aim it down
aim it down
then I could do it off to the side
in other words I don't have to go oh oh
he could be out
that same energy is here
not like oh just the end of the lever he
should have it weak deltoid this energy
here is going same place
same exact place and like if I want to
move it's loose
but I can move back into him
back into him
if I get up
you can press it down
do you see that it's not
the skeletal alignment
so watch how many times
I don't actually have
skeletal alignment or mechanical
advantage with fulcrums and levers as
we're going okay
uh
we'll go
this one
this should not be working there's a lot
of weight on there
[Music]
another one
this is energy two what you see a lot is
this here is a mechanical advantage
seen so if I go here and I brace myself
he pushes and I'm bracing here but this
is different
this is different
same thing smash the arm smash the arm
smash it he's pushing
it's still going into the ground I don't
need my hand out there
same thing I could stand up
go push
foreign
[Music]
so I'm not out external
trying to shove him down I'm trying to
figure out
how to get his energy
to no longer contest where it is
touching me and to pass through me
two times
in a young way in a Yin way
okay his energy is coming in
[Music]
where do I send it not into his
shoulders
back into his body
[Music]
okay
let's try it on the
shoulder press
okay chest goes
under her shoulders
put it in his Center
foreign
you feel that external push
when you push up his arms like that
what did we learn from the last segment
what if he's really pushing back at you
You're Gonna Go bouncing off okay
[Music]
try not to go up his arms
get your head back in place
[Music]
foreign
so we've mentioned what you're not doing
and what you're doing is that energy
going in and back out
but we are understanding that as high as
it was both true and not true
okay but how do you do it that's another
question
okay
and this part is important
because this is what makes
[Music]
skill and I can cook you
Paramount to the identity of the Ark
so there are three marks of the art this
is these are the defining marks
out outside of these three if anything
can be and everything can be
the first Mark is divine communion
however
whatever that means to you
but it has to mean this the a
reconciliation of the subject object
dichotomy
in the experiencing of life
so what you want to do the probably the
easiest way of understanding that and it
is not easy
is to just allow the religious
historical record to tell you what that
is
and when you look at what that is from
osensei's Traditions to Saint John of
the cross
it is that passive
receiving of the Divine it is Grace
you don't do it
you undo you and it happens to you
it's done through Grace
so oh since I did these possession
rituals that that's what they are
you learn how to in our discourse
deconstruct the ego tripartite
and the second mind aspect starts to
function
passively that is divine communion
well that's what you're doing when I let
your energy into me
I'm not obstructing it
I'm laying it into me
[Music]
these two things here are concentric in
their mechanisms
but they're distinct
but they're the same
structurally how they function is the
same I get out of the way and this
energy is allowed to pass through me
both ways
if we look at
what stops Divine communion
well I Define it it's your ego
tripartite
but the ego tripartite functions with
and through
fear
[Music]
so here you are and we're doing the
second Mark of Aikido the ID culture the
internal aspects
why you can't do them is you are in a
state
of abiding in fear
and fear
keeps a separation
keeps you separate from God keeps you
separate from the Divine keeps you
separate subject and object iconic
when we say Aikido is love we mean that
separation is no longer my experience we
don't just mean it psychologically we
mean it energetically we mean it
experientially
we mean it in all ways
[Music]
so if I come to this thing and you pay
attention
when he goes to do his role do you see
that
if you can't observe and gain a subtle
skill at identifying what you're feeling
and thinking at that point you will see
that you are in a dichotomous experience
right now he is pushing on me
and in that dichotomy you don't want
this to happen because you're starting
to feel a cave
and at the speed of life
you start pushing back on him
as opposed to I can keep my hands here
and change this relationship entirely
do you feel that difference so here uh
I'm gonna change it oh
and you can see I'm free again
here not free again holy cow if I move
in he's going to start tipping me over
whoa whoa
you can do it oh okay here we are I'm
gonna let it go again
and I'm free again
and that is why
the founder is right at a certain point
your Martial concern
it just gets in the way
because your Martial concern is
fear-based and dichotomous based
and that is why you can do you want to
learn Aikido
just to cook you whole
every technique is kokehold you can make
it such
not me throwing him
not me wondering will a real guy grab
you their hands like that I don't think
so
okay so as I'm doing this skill
you cannot leave the spiritual component
now because it's a spiritual thing I
gotta not feel threatened by him and the
second I'm not threatened by him that
energy passes through me
and I can move everything else
but for where I am grounding it
do you understand so
your terrible mechanics terrible
mechanics
oh I hear this release
not free again
terrible mechanic
and whatever I want to do I want to go
into his Center so I go into Center
I want him to go around me so I have him
go around
I want him to go to that corner so I
have them go to that corner
this corner over here we go to that
corner
this corner over here
I wanted to go straight back
Okay so
how do you do it
this is my
I I don't I'm not a fan of all the
Poetics
take the dragon G and move it to the
Jupiter orbit no
okay
you want to practice
a releasing skill okay and you have to
start from a place of tension first
okay I I think of it as like uh a game
where our Jenga
you're gonna take tiles away
that are not necessary for the tower to
maintain its integrity
so first you have all the tiles in place
nice tense body
okay and then he's going to start to
release things
don't let your elbows go back too far
but you have my Center okay
please see what other tiles you can take
out
and your skill
you can say is where I only need one
tile
and everything else can go to crap it's
not important okay so he's pushing and I
could be pretty relaxed
and as you get more skills you will uh
be even more relaxed
and less movement
and you can see uh what I feel is like
oh he got me there it triggered my push
on him and so adds my skill to who will
release it
not releasing it this way you could but
internal release it relax it
push it'll trigger ah release
you'll also have a separating mind when
you feel the throw got him that will
take away your internal skills do not be
concerned with the throw either just the
feeling of it going through your body
All Points of contention let them come
whatever is not involved with this
structure Let It Go release
okay
so you can think of coke you hold then
as a releasing skill development drill
that is concentric with the releasing
skill
necessary to receive the grace of divine
community
okay let's try it
[Music]
feel the desire to throw him that's a
fear-based that's a separating
psyche
just feel the energy go through you come
out of you that's all you feel
release and move can move just don't
don't push on him
[Music]
foreign
there are yogic understandings behind
all this and that's just to again
simplify the historical record
we can say in modern terms there is no
division between the mind and the body
and that is why certain thoughts
generate certain bodies it generates
certain experiences of the world okay
so
um
in order for example if I have a fear
state if I get pushed by my ego
tripartite into a dichotomous
relationship with him
that's where you try to push on you try
to push on him but we re we remembered
that if he's driving with Coq you're
going to get overpowered every single
time
well if we look at it yogically
that fear state made me go into my
shoulders
I did not keep
my shoulders out of it
I cannot keep
let's just say Center
or better said I did not keep the
formation or the organization of my body
such that his energy passed through me
and went to the ground
instead he goes to push and I locked it
up in my shoulders
which got overpowered
so you could say that here States
not only block
the receiving of energy or the receiving
of Grace
but they create blockages
at my limbs
they become separated from my body as a
whole and I become over dependent on
them
this is important because once you
understand that you understand that okay
is not at all
a barbell
uke is doing the same exact training
that I am doing
so the energy that he first gives
right once it comes bouncing back into
me I receive that energy
it like
grace of God comes into my body and I
receive it as opposed to entering into
the fear State taking a little bit more
and you feel like see how he's got me
what the afraid who care will do is
regain control
you see that and they will take that
energy out of their Center
go a little more and put it in their
arms
this is a very inefficient way of doing
koki hole
but it will lead to other
things that you can gain from okay so
you brought that up that I have a hard
time I think you should use the word
connecting with the Phuket who's
disengaging it's true okay
but from this point of view this
suitcase no longer training
so for example the same mass as I
project into him
he comes back I have that same
organization in my body
it's the exact same thing just I
received it
they afraid of your kid
who disconnects
and puts it in their shoulders
same thing here I feel it in my it's in
my shoulders again
so now I'm not training
but what you can do is and it is more
difficult
as the skilled uh nage
is it makes what you're trying to work
on
harder to to achieve so it increases
your skill in it okay so she's pushing
and she you could see already there's
nothing in her arms here so what I have
to do is find her body and this elbow do
you see how that elbow is starting to go
in
I'll show you
you're gonna have to come closer to see
all this over here
you can see from here
so I want to identify the problem so
there's no push here do you feel that
you're not displacing me at all okay
which is fine
and now I'm gonna get I'm gonna go into
where I can still get her Center
so here I am there it was did you feel
right there I am okay feel for it okay
and then watch what you do
this elbow right here
this elbow you're starting to go around
my energy
you see that okay so I go
there it is right there and then I'll
move and you're going around my head
you're feeling that energy right there
you see that and you're going around the
energy okay all I have to do and this
takes us to the third Mark of Ikea is
takamusaiki so same thing
all of this I just do spontaneously
every time she's uh moving I just keep
moving with her to keep the same Center
connection okay when I have
a good barbell he establishes the center
connection I go in and down and out and
he keeps the center connection
here are my barbell kind of wigs out on
me
when does it wig out pay attention
in other words it's not working out here
you're in my center right now do you
feel that
there it is right here this is all Lucy
juicy okay why did it do it there
who can guess
why did it not do it here push why is it
fine here
your well-balanced do you see that but
the second I go here there are there's
that mushy you see this shock absorption
of her elbows why because now you're off
balance
so what kind of emotional state are you
in
a panic right fear it's a fear State and
so now she's not in her Center okay but
for me I will just keep
constantly adjusting as she's doing that
and refining her Center through what
she's doing can you see that so you see
how she still got projected out it's not
at the end that I go here and I go
I'll keep working every time she
counters counters
and I keep going into her Center
you're going into
yourself but if you pay attention
be constantly this engages her Center
folds her elbows opens her shoulders
lets her wrist go but it doesn't matter
in some way I'm gonna find her Center
here we go
[Music]
you see all the little adjustments okay
can you feel that all right can you feel
where you try to let out the air
you're trying to take energy off okay so
the downside for you though is you're
wasting half of your training
so I would say this
[Music]
and again you have to remember you're
doing a drill
the more throwable
or the more projectable okay
it's going to be the more projecting
Noggin
they understand the body mechanics they
understand the Fearless State they can
do it back they're not wasting 50 of
their training time
okay but if I get it okay who keeps
coming out because they keep going into
a fear state
then I will use them to work on the
third Mark of Aikido which is that Taco
Mission
I I don't need her
to push on me it's just Coke you hole as
a drill
has them push on
as you work later with this skill you
should always find someone centered no
matter where you touch
their Mass itself
and its place on our gravitational plane
is enough energy that you send it
internally as we just described here
both in and down
okay you don't need that extra push and
lockout
but it is a harder skill okay
because it requires that constant
adaptations
Let's uh let's do this and that's where
the game comes in remember the other
game okay so the game which I'm not
calling Coach you hold is uh he is
trying to touch my chest
and he's trying to get out of my
encounters
you see
so in that way like the scaredy UK he
will disengage from me and try to get
himself free and I will have to be
required to all these disengagements to
still find his Center through the
disengagement okay as opposed to what is
what does this sometimes look like his
people are here like this
we got it so I'm here oh
foreign
[Music]
people will look at it and go why can't
he get off he's trying to get off he's
trying to get up it's a combination of
uh here I follow him
[Music]
so he got sold them I just followed him
but right here is an IP do you feel that
you see is it there's the adhesion right
here
so you're like why can't you go down
because the idea adhesion is there it's
starting to take his balance
so he won't go down he'll do something
else he feels that
and where I can't
uh here I don't know that feels pretty
good I might not do anything you see in
other words I kind of got a little bit
there but if necessary I'll come back on
the inside
you see and then this hand has a Coq
so he will so you see I have his mouth
so he'll try to get himself free of that
you see and again it's still there if
you pay attention
is still there so he'll try to take it
off and I followed again it is back
again
that's no different a skill than when
the security UK is trying to bleed off
energy into their Center okay so let's
play the game for a little bit yes
it's a lot of it is in your shoulders
foreign
do you feel how you're always behind
okay
that's where the adhesion comes in and
that's why you have to do it on the UK
side so you have a hundred percent
training time not 50 training time
[Music]
foreign
so right at touch you can be in her
Center
you don't have to wait for her to try to
touch your chest right right when you
touch her get in her Center she'll try
to counter by freeing her Center
in her body she'll counter
so rain tried to figure out her favorite
moves she likes she likes to control the
biceps okay and you got it for your
biceps
this is not poke you hole
[Music]
you see how she gets your biceps every
time okay now again if she has a knife
in her hand
is pushing her biceps right
here it's not really a
it kind of wins the drill but
not really the skill
[Music]
it's very slippery do you feel that so
the IQ adhesion is missing
so
uh the historical records
of let's keep
Divine communion thus the historical
record of divine Community is not a
common experience
statistically it is an uncommon
experience
is does everyone have the potential yes
they do
does everyone who is seeking to achieve
it no
likewise
as the internal aspects Coq and I.T are
just concentric
manifestations
of divine communion
if you look at the historical record
does across the traditions
is it a great number of people who can't
do it no no it's not
is it guaranteed that everyone puts
themselves on the pot is going to
achieve those skills no it's not and
they tell you it's not the case
is it possible for everyone yes it is
but if you understand it in terms
that I described here
we can say it's only as possible as we
can cease existing in a fear state
and now you know
not only is it not possible for everyone
but at certain times and under certain
conditions
even someone who could do it under other
conditions and at other times might not
be able to do it here and now
this is important because to me
oftentimes trying to do it
is just another fear State and gets in
the way
and you can't do it
so you're trying to get that that person
not to touch your chest and all of that
trying is all fear and now you're just
tense in your shoulders there's no
adhesion it's very slippery and you're
constantly following someone which means
you're reactionary but there's no chance
you're going to get it it's a matter of
time only before they get it
[Music]
and this is why
as Aikido kilonwasa
can be considered just koku whole in
general it's all Cookie whole
and that koku Hall is about developing a
particular skill
or a particular Body Mind organization
than any martial concern
has to include elements outside of kilo
noisa
[Music]
you don't fight with keho nozzo
when you're doing your Coq hole you're
not training to fight
you're training a skill set
that could be used marshally
but you have to go on and figure out how
to use that skill set Martian just like
straight
[Music]
as I mentioned earlier if you understand
that
you can liberate yourself
from
[Music]
the incessant message
of self-defense
and as someone attacking you
and and you stopping them
or you gaining victory over them because
you threw them
and instead
instead of self-defense it's
self-release
[Music]
so I'm not trying to throw him I'm not
trying to stop him from touching my
chest
if you pay attention every time you you
you try to stop them before that
micro sparked from a stone timing before
that
you already were in that state of fear
that this bad thing was going to happen
and then you got into your shoulders and
you just started bracing on them
and in the game depending on the kid's
nature
they either overpowered you or they just
slipped around you and touched your
chest
every time that that thing happened that
process happened
fear dichotomy limb isolation
overpowered or too slow
not adhering enough can't stay up with
them
so
as we now look at ourselves and make a
problem out of our effort to achieve
something
even this noblest self-defense or even
as Noble as I want Divine communion
[Music]
but understand that that's what is
exactly stopping me from getting it
then we can in some way hopefully
reorient ourselves in our training
and then maybe
again not guaranteed Maybe
we can reconcile fear
and receive Grace
there's no guarantee
but all that said you are much better
living a life
where you've made a problem of fear and
you have a practice wherein you try to
reconcile fear
and you Aspire and Orient yourselves
towards receiving Grace than if you
binge watch Netflix and get all social
justice out and try to have a job that
gives you meaning
and use their soulmate
to bring your meaning and all that
secular material is
it's it should be a no-brainer now
the culture's not working
we're going mentally ill
we're spiritually bankrupt
we need to return to these paths
so yes you're going to struggle with
tense relax tense relax tense relaxed
[Music]
but even tense relaxed tense relaxed
tends relaxed so in other words
you're like he's pushing and you're like
and then you go relax and you just that
kick yeah that's not it
that's not it
but this desire or let's say the
possibility of fluctuating between tense
relaxed it all comes from the same
state of being it all comes from a fear
state it all comes from a
self-attachment state
I just I know it sounds weird but all I
do is stick
and
it looks like you can touch it but he
knows the more he pushes he goes into
his body
and then I know that the more I relax
the more it goes into his body as
opposed to I start putting it in my
shoulder now it's just stronger stronger
and he starts to slip do you feel how
you're slipping
so you can get very frustrated you're
like I don't know what to do that is the
door
that is the door you want to walk
through that sounds crazy but if you
look at the historical record tradition
after tradition has told you finally you
found the door
finally you got here now walk through
the door
stop knowing so much
start abiding in I don't know what to do
okay so you can't go tense release okay
stop all of those stop Muslims don't do
those don't do those
okay well I don't know what to do good
good your problem was you knew what to
do
okay
[Music]